you don't keep track of my career but
I watch yours
is there anybody I know that CMS always
likes to start is there anybody that
would like to start besides CMS not that
you can't start you may start
you want to you want to jump up and work
Felix okay let's do it
yeah let's do it
okay
so for your edification uh David and
Karen what we do first uh we we tape all
our memorized scenes from last week
uh all we've done is uh
re-read through them last week and uh
sort of chatted about them a little bit
take a look at uh I'm not a believer in
method or any of that stuff the process
we use on one degree of separation from
Sanford Meisner although we do not do
repetition exercises here uh what we do
however is uh improvisation cold reading
which I like to call sight reading like
in music and we work consistently on
storytelling working Moment by moment
and impulse by impulse and that's what
these guys do so the first thing we do
is tape the scenes that we sort of read
through last week
uh Felix and then we'll uh take a quick
break potty break water break coffee
break candy break
and then we will do cold reads for next
week so that sort of brings you up to
speed
keep your papers still people
please maybe he's good
we'll start to see I do
hello Howard hello Peter
I was just passing by and thought I'd
drop in
you know I haven't seen you in such a
long time
did you know that guy Franco made me his
partner last week
no
you know you don't keep track of my
career but
I watch yours
yeah it's called francon and Keating now
and I guess I don't have to tell you
that guy friend Khan is the leading
architect in the country right now no
you don't have to tell me that yeah
remember how I told you once that I'd
rise
are you uh
are you waiting for something Howard
you were telling me about guy francone
right I was just telling you about
something I had once predicted
you know I hate to see it down like this
man
you remember how we started
and look at us now
how much more of this can you take what
did you come here Peter because we're
old friends and I hate to see you beaten
oh I'm not there's no use in lying about
it you haven't had a client in a year oh
you're wrong
it's been a year and a half right and
you might have a couple hundred dollars
left and then that's it
fourteen dollars
oh and 57 cents right right and all
those bills I mean this is an unpaid
light bill isn't it oh no no that is a
disconnect notice oh and that
that's an eviction notice right so how
much more of that can you take
that's my concern not yours you know you
can pay me back whenever you want by the
way you need it
Peter no thank you I don't need your
help
but I want to help
look I don't give or ask for help
why don't you drop it what the charade
or the pose or the ideals or whatever
you want to call it
you can't stand alone anymore just give
in
learn how to get along with people first
of all
and then start designing the buildings
that everyone else does and you will be
rich
you will be successful you'll be
affluent you'll
you'll finally be one of us
is that what's bothering you
oh that I want to stand alone
is that it
I don't know
look it's getting late go home Peter if
you lost your watch Howard I hawked it
good night
good luck
and cut all right how'd that feel pretty
good that's good should have felt good
yeah it was pretty strong he's very good
pretty strong so it's well you know
here's the deal acting as a team sport
if you don't want to be an active member
of a team sport don't be an actor you
don't act alone even someone doing a
one-person show doesn't act alone they
have a crew they have a sound booth they
have camera people it you don't do it
alone so if you're concerned about your
lines and your memorization which as we
get older does happen
then you depend on your partner to help
you in the event that something goes
awry
okay
and it will so don't think it won't
because it will
you know I've worked with actors making
a half a million dollars a week that
couldn't remember their lines
they were still making a half a million
dollars a week
you know okay so what
you know I could tell you a long story
about Pernell Roberts and I guess
starring on a very very large major show
and both of us seasoned actors wanted to
kill the two young actors we were
working with because they kept screwing
around and horsing around
and he was a fire chief and I was a fire
captain and we kept burning down
buildings it was not an easy shoot there
were three crews you were literally
bringing up literally yeah literally
burning down I thought it was a metaphor
no no no no no no no it was a actual
situation yeah so okay I like uh go in
there
be a little more
intrusive at the very beginning
you want to Utz him a little bit you're
not there to help him
and at the beginning of the scene this
time it sounded as though you're really
there to help but you're not you're
there to gloat
you're there to stick it to him you're
there to put that little final last pin
in the voodoo doll
whatever
and you just don't want to deal with it
you don't give a about him
you know why I should have just slammed
the door in his face yeah well and in
actuality maybe you would have done that
in real life but he sort of barges in
you don't really have a choice
you know and this is the sequence that
was written by the writer so you have to
do it what do you want to or not it's
not real life no it's not it's not real
life and it's not life imitating art or
art imitating life
you know French Watcher froze said it
the best filmmaking is capturing life at
24 frames a second
that's what filmmaking is and it's our
job to be as realistic and honest and
open and willing to be those things
for people to enjoy what we do
that's our job your job isn't your
objective or your motivation or any of
that crap I'll tell you what your
objective is your objective is to get
the job your motivations to get paid
yeah and hope to check no he stay clear
you may have to fight for it sometimes
but they normally clear let's do this
again
be a little more standoffs at the
beginning you're sort of
I don't know
not sure whether you were happy to see
him not happy to see him so let's be a
little more definitive about that
something obviously it doesn't matter
what it was because you know the old
David Mammoth story I tell with the
executive producer calling him and
saying well how long was the guy in
Germany and David says how the hell
should I know I don't know we said you
wrote the script yeah but he could have
been there five minutes five years five
days I don't know doesn't matter it's
not part of the story he just was in
Germany who cares so we don't know what
transpired between these two people but
it's important for you
to have an instantaneous response to how
he comes into the sequence
okay got it okay cool we ready in the
booth my good still chill
yeah both of you both you are still good
hello Howard
hello Peter this is just passing by and
thought I'd drop in
you know I haven't seen you in like
forever
uh did you know that guy friend car made
me his partner last week
no yeah
yeah you know you don't keep track of my
career but
I watch yours
yeah it's called francon Keating now and
I guess I don't have to tell you that
guy friend caused the leading architect
in the country right now no you don't
have to tell me
remember how I told you once that I'd
rise remember how I told you that
are you waiting for something Howard
you're telling me about guy friend con
right yeah I was just telling you about
what I once predicted so
you know
I hate to see you down like this man
yep you remember how we started
and look at us now
haven't you had enough
why did you come here Peter because
we're old friends and
I hate to see you beaten
I'm not
oh it's no use in lying about it I mean
you haven't had a client in a year
you're wrong
it's been a year and a half right you
might have a couple hundred dollars left
and then that's it
oh
see
um yeah
what's 14 and uh
57 cents oh it's impressive you think
that's enough to pay off all the bills I
mean this is a it's an unpaid light bill
isn't it no that's a disconnect notice
and that's an eviction notice
how much more of that can you take
what's the reason you came here Peter
why are you here well
you know I want to help
and
you've given me a couple indications
here that that'd probably be the best
thing to do but
no thanks no thanks Peter I don't want
your help thank you you sure yeah I
don't give or ask for help Peter okay
when are you gonna drop it what
this
this the charade or the pose
or the ideals
look
you can't stand alone anymore
just give in
learn how to get along with people first
of all
because that's always been a weak point
of yours and once you learn how to do
that
start designing the buildings that
everyone else designs and then you will
finally be rich
you'll be affluent you'll be respected
and you'll finally be one of us
I see so that's what's bothering you
right now is
that I want to stand alone
is that it
you know Howard
I don't know
yeah Peter
you don't it's late go home oh right
have you lost your watch Howard I hawked
it good night
good luck
see ya bye
and cut there we go there we go nice
nice nice so here's the thing I say it
all the time don't get sick of it but
the only way that the audience can be
interested is if you are interesting
sharing form we've got to be interested
in what we're watching otherwise we go
pee-pee or go get a Coke or go get a big
bucket of popcorn or not off in the
theater exactly right good work the
changes are very good very specific all
very natural all very here's the thing
active listening active listening I I
get right before covid some of you know
I got to spend a whole evening with
Morgan Freeman it's one of the things we
talked about the most where was I uh you
weren't invited
anyway we talk about active listening he
said that's the most important thing he
ever learned from any of the Stars he
was ever fortunate enough to work with
is to listen and I was watching what was
I watching oh I started watching don't
ask me why because I'm not a big fan but
I started watching on uh Prime right
and there's a scene but he's talking
he's going through this wonderful
monologue and they cut to and he's not
listening
and because of the way we work
I knew he wasn't listening so with a
couple of people I was sitting and
watching with I said what do you see
here what's not right I think well he's
not listening he was pretending to
listen
but he wasn't listening what you can
tell
and when it was time for his line
they cut to him and he had been thinking
about his line all the time
and it was apparent that's what he was
doing now maybe I did the average Joe
schmoe they may or may not see that
but you guys certainly would have
and the people I was sitting with are
not one's a writer and and one's a sales
marketing person
they're not aware of that
but they sensed it because he wasn't
listening so your listening skills guys
the more you do this
are getting better and better and better
and better and I say this all the time
ad nauseam I realized but the only way
the uncomfortable becomes comfortable is
by doing the uncomfortable it's the only
way the reason is a totally different
personality than he was two and a half
years ago
well and it's exemplified in his work
you get the out of the way get
yourself out of the way and all of a
sudden things open up for you you know
it's a good good work thank you good
good work you know thank you guys don't
go buy a book about terms of the
industry either I'll teach those to you
week by week we'll go through all those
terms
you need some help everybody
I have Bonnie Gillespie's book it's
pretty good so far Bonnie's one of the
only books about the industry that I
would highly recommend
it's really fabulous
and she's a very gracious giving human
being she gives away a lot of her time
and her energy
and you showed meisner's book the other
day I had read that one
I forgot what it was called
but when you had it even the other day
yeah I think Genie borrowed it
she's really neat to find out what not
to do yeah I disagree
well you talked a lot about repetition
well that's what he based his whole
thing on and that's why my mentor and
Coach Charles Conrad
broke away from Sanford and came out
here and opened his own Studio but
that's another story all good things
evolved oh yeah
okay you guys ready camera's ready
who starts
rolly
dad
what's wrong with Grandma
she's real sick honey
is she going to die
everybody dies someday
I mean is she going to die soon
son come here for a minute and let's
talk I don't want to upset you but
yes
yes she is going to die soon
foreign
but
I don't want Grandma to die
can't the doctors help her they've done
everything they could
for now
the best we can hope for
is for her to be comfortable
she didn't even know me earlier today
when you get old the body gets worn out
and things stop working the brain is
just one of them
but
Grandma to die I'm
tired
either she's my mother and nobody can
ever replace her
mom died
everybody I love dying dad
how come all the good people in the
world are dying
I don't know
I guess God needs him in heaven to help
him so what why is God taking away all
the people I love what did I ever do to
make him mad you didn't make him mad
you're a good kid
and besides he hasn't taken everyone I'm
still here and I'm not leaving you
promise
mom promised she would never leave
either and she did
she lied
and you're lying too
You're Gonna Leave me just like
everybody else did not for a long
long time I promise I'm going to stay
here
and watch your kids grow up
I'm not going to have any kids
and that way they can't die
and cut lovely good for you that one
actually hurts of course it hurts it's a
painful piece of course it hurts it's
supposed to if it didn't hurt you
wouldn't be human
see that's what's so wonderful about
this process that Charles taught me and
that I teach you that's Charles Eric
Conrad for those of you that don't know
he was not only my acting coach for 12
years but he was my friend and Mentor
for 40. and that's why this process is
so wonderful because it allows you to
experience the pain
that you would be feeling if you're
actually going through the situation you
don't have to fabricate anything I'm
sorry what yeah
I just hit this
kid it's his brother
Ricky's his brother
so he lost his mother and his brother
and now he's losing his grandma
so you can allow yourself to feel a
little bit more pain if you want to on
this second time okay
don't hold back
I want to compliment you not one upbeat
tonight not one
not one good for you kiddo
you know we've been working on that
fine-tuning it they're all little things
we work on you all know I do not believe
in constructive criticism I think it's
an oxymoron I don't think you could
build something up and tear it down at
the same time but what we can do
is because we tape everything and we
look at everything and we see everything
and we send you free copies of
everything we shoot here
we can evaluate
we can see what's working what's not
working
what you're hiding from us
see in theater and I love theater don't
anybody say I don't know theater I've
done theater my whole life I love
theater you can get away you can cheat a
little bit in theater
you can't cheat on film
crawls in your eyes and in your guts
counts the nose hairs in your nose and
magnifies everything you do and feel
so you can't cheat
you know and that's what's so wonderful
about Charles process
it allows you once you get your head the
right space once you go from your left
brain which is The Logical brain to your
right brain which is a creative brain
once you go there
it allows you to experience things on a
real natural personal level but you have
to have the willingness to go there
see and a lot of people when they're new
here don't have that willingness they
don't want us to see them warts and all
they want to smile through everything or
be tougher than everyone but that's not
the way life is
you know
pain Agony and torture
is what life is I'm not a fatalist but I
am a realist
you know
so allow yourself to feel that pain when
we do this again see where John is do
you see where John's coming from as as
the uh son of the woman who's your
grandma who's dying he tells you you say
I don't want Grandma to die and he what
does he tell you he said
why that's his mom
yeah
pretty serious stuff isn't it
yeah so just feel a little bit more okay
let yourself go there
just don't give a hoot you know what I
normally say but we're being taped the
nights I have to be blind yeah
and trying not to swear too much
they could bleep it out
that's not the way I usually up we're a
great goodness
no so okay so we good in the booth
okay
okay we're rolling we have speed another
Mark action
Dad what's wrong with Grandma
she's real said Connie
is she going to die
everybody dies someday
I mean is she going to die soon
son come here a minute let's talk
now
I don't want to upset you
but yes
she is going to die soon
but
I don't want Grandma to die
can't the doctors help her
they've done everything they could
now the best we can hope for is for her
to be comfortable
she didn't even know who I was earlier
today
when you get old
your body's
breaks down things stop working the
brain is just one of them
I don't
ha
I don't want Grandma to die
I don't want her to die either
she's my mother and nobody can ever
replace her
you can't believe this
mom died and
little Mickey died
how come everybody I love is dying how
come all the good people in the world
are dying dead
I don't know
I guess God needs him in heaven to help
him book
why is God taking everybody away from me
what did I ever do to make him mad you
haven't done anything to make God mad
you're a good kid and besides he hasn't
taken everyone
I'm still here and I'm not leaving you
promise
I promise mom promised she would never
leave me there
and she did she lied and you're lying
too
You're Gonna Leave me just like Mom did
I just like little Mickey did
not for a long long time I promise
I'm gonna stay right here and watch your
kids grow up
I'm not going to have any kids
that way they can't die
and cut oh nice really lovely yeah good
work good work Blake really good
yeah nice Mr Keating thank you really
super super let's do uh Andrea
oh I started you still do the cold
reading right can you zoom out uh like
everything yeah
what did Yoda say there's no try there
is doing not do
and anybody that doesn't cold read aloud
30 minutes every day gets doo doo
that's how I read novels because I can
never read anything right I started
reading 1984 it's actually really good
I'm cold reading that now George Orwell
like why haven't I read that before yeah
it's a great book it's really good
remember guys readers aren't leaders but
leaders are readers
Perry Truman
want to be a leader in any field you got
to be a reader I mean it's so good that
the 30 minutes of like the thing by bell
rings and I'm like really what I like
your body good good you time your
reading that's good
how are we in the booth
oh I start yeah of course
you know what I admire most about you
I don't know is it my brilliant mine
or my gorgeous insatiable body
the way you're so goddamn cheerful the
way you did the cartwheels today
fantastic ah nothing to it
it's a champagne and
me it's not that easy Chrissy
people are different you're just so open
to people everyone I'm not that way I've
got walls built around me why why not
just straighten that I
well I mean it's not that easy
buy a lot of up things happened
to me when I was a kid
a lot of up things happen to a
lot of people when they were kids maybe
so but I've learned to tune things out
not like people too close
I mean work is great I'm work I'm great
at work but people hurt you and what you
don't feel can't hurt you
okay see that's what's wrong Philly
it's not feeling
opened up
you've got to learn to love people
you've got to love stupid people
bag ladies finals you know dirty old man
and I know how it made sound but
they're people you know they're live
it's and it that's the greatest thing in
the universe
it's so
beautiful and sacred
and it's free
it's all around us
just dig it wallow in it
wow
you're so damn great Chrissy
okay see I don't understand you
I really don't
I don't understand this thing with you
and your grandfather
well why can't you just forget the old
fart already
it's like a family curse or something
it's hard to explain my grandfather my
grandfather is Texas
I mean he thinks he could buy anything
he wants
if you try to buy me once and what he
can't buy he wants to destroy does that
make sense to you
not really
he destroyed my father no way we
crippled him
you shouldn't ignore Wade you either
love him or hate him
and what about Jenny cheerleader why
can't you just forget about her
oh Jenny well Jenny's special
even even if I never saw her again she'd
still be special
she dumped over you okay just quit
moaning about her
sorry Chrissy
you're wonderful
come on today maybe some good healthy
sex we'll bring it back to your
remembrance so
oh wow
let's go and cut there we go lovely good
for you you're you're you know your your
English do you do you realize how much
better your English is now than it was
six months ago yeah man there's just a
huge difference and just by doing it
cold raining a lot every day you do have
the exercise that I gave everybody right
you doing that now I have a lovely uh
gal from uh Brazil Portuguese who's
working on that exercise with me and
doing a fabulous job and Vasily of
course has worked on it for months since
he's been here and it just shows so
you're working real hard at it good for
you that's a lovely work lovely work bed
you okay it's a lot of crap
I was like that there's no cussing in
this why did I say that no well I don't
care because I haven't said the f word
tonight you thought you'd fill in for me
yeah we have an F quarter tonight so uh
we're we're meeting it blank you be
quiet uh no f word for you although you
did say it one night which was quite a
wonderful uh it warmed the cockles over
[Laughter]
dad stop talking like that around the
kids
okay good all right let's do it again
um no I I like what you did just change
it up just give me a different read
you know okay
but I just go no no you'll get your
words from the booth
all right you starved you
we are rolling
take your own action
you know what I admire the most about
you
my real and Minds
or my gorgeous insatiable body
the way you're so goddamn cheerful all
the time
the way you did those cartwheels earlier
on fantastic uh nothing to it you know
the year was champagne to make me drunk
it's not that easy people are different
you're so open to people to everyone I'm
not that way I've got walls around me
why though why not just cheer them down
it's not that easy a lot of crap
happened to me when I was a kid
I love crap happens to everyone when
they were a kid
maybe so but I've learned to tune things
out not to let anybody too close and
work is great I mean I'm great at work
but people hurt you
you
can't be hurt by things you don't feel
that's wrong food
that's not how it works
you you've got to open up
you've got to learn how to love people
you've you've got to love
all those Winos and stupid people
and bag ladies and dirty old men
because they're people
in their life
and that's the greatest thing in the
universe
it's beautiful and it's sacred and it's
free
it's all around us
dig in it wallow in it
you're so damn great Chrissy
I don't understand
I I really don't
this thing with you and your grandfather
why can't you just forget the old fart
already
it's like a family curse or something
I can't explain my grandfather my
grandfather is Texas
I mean he thinks he could buy anything
he wants he tried to buy me once and
what he doesn't buy he wants to destroy
does that make sense to you I don't
think so
he destroyed my dad no wait crippled him
but you can't ignore Wade either love
him or hate him and what about Jenny
cheerleader
can you just forget about her oh Jenny
well you know Jenny's special even if I
never see her again she's still special
oh look she dumped all over you
you need to understand
that there was a point in my life when
my mother and Jenny were the only people
I cared about
okay so how Jenny what about me
oh
I'm sorry Chrissy you're wonderful
hmm
come to Bedford maybe some good healthy
sex will help you bringing you back to
your senses
okay and cut there we go nice you get
shot the hell out of Phillips
I was ready to run upstairs but uh that
I had forgotten that line good that's
good good good good good good lovely
good work okay uh Kenny and Max
uh my students quote me all the time
have one of the hottest up-and-comers in
Nashville who studied with us and is in
our movie played the dad in our movie
and he says that every time he goes on
stage he says I'm take he told me this
the other day he says I I carry your bag
of tools with me every time I go on
stage that's a great compliment
Al okay simmer down
now sit down now
we are rolling we have speed we have a
mark
and action
of course you resent it but you should
know there's a simple way to silence all
these unjust criticisms if you were just
to produce some accounts and why should
I
why should I submit to The Bullying of
the diocesan's offices
why should I open up private files so
you can appease your obstreperous
archdeacon
who is currently brow beating you into
taking an undignified and undefying
stance
and if I do give in to this request I
will be taking a serious
I understand your anger
but you should know
I you know I see a point of view
Stephen you've got to listen to me what
I'm about to tell you
sorry could we start over on that I was
not feeling that I was not knowing that
that's okay it's okay can I review my my
script really quick sure don't get up
we'll bring it up
it's all right
supervisor what kind of a script
consultant are you
everybody
geez it's hard to find good help
Karen Can You Feel The Love you feel the
love here all we have is love
see don't screw up again dammit Max
who knows I'm just kidding
Focus guys take your time Max obviously
forgot the number one lesson have a
break
also it is ridiculously warm in here you
are wearing it or you're wearing a wool
jacket what the heck
you have a hole in your armpit or
something you don't want us to see your
shirt or what
[Laughter]
I'm joking but yeah
okay give him a minute guys
we're rolling
take your own action
of course you resent it
but you should know there's a simple way
to silence all these unjust criticisms
fewer just to produce some accounts then
why should I
why should I submit to The Bullying of
the Diocesan offices
why do I need to produce files private
files just so you can appease your
archdeacon who is currently brow beating
you into taking an undignified and
undefined stance
if I were to give in
I would be taking the most dangerous
precedent
now believe me the
the canons will have my back up the hilt
in asserting the dean and chapter's
ability to withstand any any
interference from the archdeacon
or any of his ordering of the
cathedral's affairs
I understand your anger and I see your
point of view
but Stephen
please I beg of you please listen
carefully to what I'm about to say
I myself don't see any
deliberate issue
but it should be a fact that anyone even
someone as financially enjoyed as you
can commit a mistake that proves
expensive
if there is indeed and made a mistake
somewhere along the line please tell me
right now so I could give you my full
support and sorting out all these
consequences
I can understand whether it be
circumstances where talking to the
canons wouldn't be in your best
favor but
please know that I'm on your side with
this
how extremely kind of you
but I am in no need of a Confessor
I should also warn you that if you
continue to persist in your refusal to
cooperate with me
I shall feel obliged to make a
visitation don't make it
I hope you enjoy the moment when I
present you with Immaculate accounts and
that's a very irresponsible attitude for
seeing your Churchman to adopt shouldn't
you be thinking of ways you could best
avoid unfortunately shouldn't you
I don't understand this this lust this
lust to play the grand Inquisitor of the
chapters houses more than a little
distasteful
you are only supposed to go around and
be everybody's fathering God not prying
into the cathedral's Affairs like some
fraud Squad detective now let me repeat
everything is
fine
I have control of everything and the
appeal is on course so why don't you go
back to your little job of playing the
good bishop and leave me in peace to
play the Good Dean because I know from
past experience that the role of good
Dean is one that you sometimes have
great troubles how dare you how dare you
hardly think you're in the right to
complain when I follow your example so
Stephen
just have a conversation
in a calm and civilized and dare I say
Christian manner
let's try to get a hold of ourselves
I
don't want to have a visitation but I
think that is a lie you've been longing
for years to make a visitation so you
can run my Thrace my face through the
mud
and don't think I don't know why
you haven't forgiven me have you you
haven't forgot that I may have made a
pass at your wife
and the problem is your wife didn't seem
too upset about it are you bloody liar
you bloody liar she was never interested
in you she fought you off I know she did
not you worked hard for a long time she
didn't fight it all
it's a good thing I didn't have a drink
now you always have too much to drink I
mean the only reason you spend your
entire damn life committing adultery is
because you're always too well
righteous hypocritical righteous and
hypocritical about telling the truth
it's not the truth
I I speak the truth when I tell you you
are self-righteous and hypocritical how
dare you accuse me of immorality when
you are the one who went to bed last
night with Harriet March and don't
pretend you don't know what I'm talking
about and don't act like I will keep
quiet for the good of the church either
in fact
in fact go ahead and make that
visitation
because if you do I will go up to
Harriet's highest friends in London and
tell them about the affair
and then the news of the world will be
on your doorstep quicker than you can
draw a breath to lie about your
innocence there wasn't an affair that's
not what Harriet happened but she's
lying well I don't trust you and I don't
believe you and neither will the news of
the world well that's it you just
convinced me without a shadow of doubt
that you are utterly unfit to be the
dean of a great Cathedral I will force
you at a star Bridge even if it's the
very last thing I
the minute the minute you you got past
that hump yeah you know that little
hurdle it really started rocking yeah
and this is why
I've never had an actor in 30 years of
coaching get on a set for the first time
and be uncomfortable
the chances of you getting a roll like
this at the stages that most of you are
are 10 million to one
so if you can do this here and produce
as well as you did
five lines eight lines on the Shonda
Rhimes show
who cares
you'll go in and kick ass yeah you'll
get the job done you'll do really well
and you'll get you know I just had one
of my actors just guest starred on on uh
Chicago Med and now uh he's guest
starring on uh on uh Power book four
so
this works guys this process works you
don't have to get your book of herbs you
you don't have to dissect a script you
don't have time for it you just don't
have time
you know
you get a call on Friday
for an audition on Friday morning you
get a call back Friday afternoon
you're on the set Monday morning
when you do backstory when do you do
research you don't have time
five things to look at on every script
five things real simple who what where
when why done
here's a question for you guys if you
are in scenes four five and six scenes
31 32 and 33 and scenes 89 91 and 92 do
you have to read the whole script
no
why
that's information you don't need it's
not your story it's not your story
you're concerned with the scenes you're
in
I love when Harvey Keitel gave De Niro
the uh Kennedy awards Center award
he was up there and he looked up at
Bobby and he says Bobby I want to thank
you for teaching the most important
thing about memorization my line my line
my line my
line my line
my line my line okay it's not that
simple of course but there's no reason
for you to know what's going on in the
story if you're not involved in part of
that story
why
what's the first thing about
screenwriting the first rule about
screening right writing is if it doesn't
add to the story take it out of the
screenplay
you see it all the time in movies so go
from one sequence to another
you sort of what
but then you think back and think oh it
didn't matter
it doesn't matter
if it doesn't add to the story doesn't
matter if what you're going to read
about is only going to clutter your
brain with excess matter
why do we need to know it we don't
how long was a guy in Germany
I don't care
I don't care I'm not in that scene
I don't care if you you know spend his
life there
okay it's a ball buster guys and I I
doffed my hat you know and but this is
why we're here this is why all the
material we have is original material
and I purposely pull material that's
going to be hard for you that's going to
take you out of your comfort zone
that's going to make you break down
that's going to keep you from smiling
all the time you're not my only Smiler
anymore
no no no The Smiling though they're
smiling in that sequence was wonderful
but you remember used to do that a lot I
have a beautiful gal in Wednesday
morning who does the same thing not
anymore she did six months ago she
smiled through everything I could give
her a funeral sequence he'd be smiling
you know she didn't want me to see what
was going on inside of her
well you have to be willing to do that
you have to be willing to show me
you know you guys were furious with each
other
and it wasn't about the church and it
wasn't about money it was about who whom
it's personal it was personal
it was personal and it became very
personal for both of you in the sequence
and because it was personal it became
visceral for me
okay yeah
don't you cry make me cry
okay we good in the booth yeah
okay Mr Abner you've got the con
I'm trying to hold for a few seconds of
sound holding for sound
like a motorcyclists
hey that's Frontier Airlines to you oh
sorry
oh yeah
spirited Frontier
I think we're clear now okay take your
time guys focus a minute
we're rolling
or take your own action
of course you were sent it
but you should know there is an easy way
to silence all these unjust criticisms
if you were to produce some accounts
then why should I
why should I
submit to The Bullying of the diocesan's
offices
why should I open up private files so
that you can appease your obstreperous
archdeacon who is currently brow beating
you into taking an undignified and
undefying stance
and if I were to give in to this request
I'd be setting the most dangerous
precedent
now I assure you
the Cannons have my back to the hilt and
asserting the dean and chapters ability
to withstand any interference from the
archdeacon and The Ordering of the
cathedral's affairs
I understand your anger and I see your
point of view but Stephen I beg of you
please listen very carefully to what I'm
about to say
I personally don't see any deliberate
wrongdoing
but it is a fact that anyone even
someone as financially enjoyed as you
can commit a mistake that proves
expensive
there really has been a mistake made
somewhere along the line please tell me
now so I could back you completely
but
I also can understand that there are
these circumstances that speaking to the
canons wouldn't be in your favor
and I'd be failing you as your Bishop if
I didn't at least give you the chance to
confide in me
wow how extremely kind of you but I am
in no need of a Confessor I should also
warn you that if you persist in your
refusal to cooperate with me I shall
feel obliged to make a visitation
that make it
and I hope you enjoy what you find when
I present you Immaculate accounts that's
a very irresponsible attitude for senior
Churchman to adopt if Jenny you'll be
thinking of ways to best avoid
unfortunately
listen to yourself
this lust to become this Grand
Inquisitor of the chapter's house is
more than a little sickening
your job is to go around being
everybody's father and God not prying
into the cathedral's Affairs like some
Mob Squad Detective
now listen to me when I tell you
everything is fine
I have everything under control
the appeal is on course so why don't you
do me a favor and go back to your job
and play the good little Bishop
and leave me in peace to play the Good
Deen because I know from past experience
that the role of a good Dean is one that
you sometimes have great troubles to
stay oh how dare you how dare you since
you insist on calling a spade a spade I
hardly think you're in the right to
complain when I follow your example
so Stephen let's get a grip on ourselves
and try to have a conversation in a calm
civilized and dare I say Christian
manner I'll start by offering some
information that is true and which I
hope you all accept as a peace offering
signifying my good intentions
I don't want to have a visitation
and I think it'd be infinite infinite
letter for the time it is a lie you have
been longing for years to make a
visitation here so you could rub my face
in the mud and don't think I don't know
why you still haven't forgiven me you
haven't forgotten that I may have made a
pass at your wife
and you haven't forgotten that she
wasn't as upset as she should have been
you bloody liar you bloody liar she was
never interested in you she fought you
off I know she thought you would not
fight that hard and for a while she did
not fight at all
good thing I didn't have too much to
drink why you always have so much to
drink the only reason why you don't
spend your entire damn life committing
adultery is because you're always too
bloody sought into a self-righteous
hypocritical so self-righteous and
hypocrite
I am speaking the truth when I call you
self-righteous and hypocritical
now how dare you accuse me of immorality
when you just last night were in bed
with Harriet March
no don't act like you don't know what
I'm talking about
and don't think for once I will keep
silence for the good of the church in
fact if you go through with this
visitation I shall reach out to
Harriet's highest friends in London and
tell them about the affair and then the
news of the world will be on your
doorstep quicker than you can come up
with a lie about your innocence but
there wasn't any Affair so whatever
you'd have to say but she's lying
well good for you
because I don't trust you and neither
will the news of the world
that's it you just convinced me without
a shadow of doubt that you are utterly
unfit to be the dean of a great
Cathedral I will force you out of
storage even if it's the very last thing
I ever do
and cut there we go nice
nice nice nice
solid see that's that's that's some of
the best most relaxed
unaffected work that you've ever done
do you feel it yeah do you feel it
you've got to feel it you've got to feel
I can't make you feel it I can't get you
that up to that place it's easy to me
get mad at me
no I'm the widest person here
good work guys
okay I was already sweating like a dog
oh my gosh
it's up to you
uh we could do uh Rochelle and Kai but
then Jeannie has to work back to back
and I don't know that Genie wants to do
that so I'm thinking we should take a
break okay break time
coffee time break time water Time Candy
time
we are rolling sound is speeding
we have a mark
action
you're not leaving
I have to go
this is ridiculous you you sneak in here
unannounced you drink all of my wine you
me you leave me high and dry then
you go to the bathroom for like half an
hour and then you saunter off through
the dark and you start getting dressed
as if I wouldn't notice and without any
explanation it's pretty obvious that you
go to your dinner party okay
come on don't get angry I told you I was
going to the dinner party last week I
reminded you about the dinner party when
I arrived this afternoon
a couple hours ago you didn't seem to
mind you were very welcoming
I know but I
I changed my mind okay I changed my mind
I mean especially since this
since it's hours together in bed I mean
normally we have supper together and we
cuddle and I just
I just thought I thought we were gonna
do that tonight Shane I thought we were
gonna do that
okay well look
don't it's fine
don't make yourself feel guilty about
anything or anything like that okay I'm
not mad
just look it doesn't matter Michelle it
doesn't it doesn't matter nothing
matters okay it does matter it matters
to me I mean it's pretty obvious after
tonight that something else is going on
it's pretty obvious that you can't be
with me because there's another woman
okay
so what does that prove
I think you're a bastard for using me I
haven't used you oh I haven't used you
yes you have and I think Dave Hartley's
a bastard too for not inviting me to
that stupid dinner party too
okay well he's not putting it on Allison
Ridley is and she doesn't know you she
doesn't know about our relationship
we both decided that we'd have Separate
Lives separate friends and we wouldn't
become that perfect twosome okay our
relationship has never had any strings
because of you if I recall correctly
yeah well I
I changed my mind okay I changed my mind
Shane okay
I love you Shane and I just I I I want
to go with you tonight I'm can I can I
please just
no you can't
not this little hour it's a seated
dinner party okay so stop trying to make
me feel guilty
of course of course I'm not involved in
your inner little circle and it makes me
want to puke all of you the heartlies
the oh hairs the O'Neills all of them
make me want to puke
you're so pretentious in your own little
Circle never allowing any
Outsiders ever
you with your old money you know you're
never allowing anybody but you guys you
know I think it is I think it's
incestuous all you do is hang out with
your country club people and your
Beverly Hills mansions and you never
allow anyone from the outside it's sick
I have to go I'm very late
you know I'm really sorry that this uh
had it ended on a bad note
there's nothing else to be said so
I really wish we could have been friends
though
friends
got to have mine friends
why don't you go with that right
oh is she debutant part of like a
country club is that why you don't bring
her around I bet you just got that
dinner
you know there's one thing I don't
understand every single time you come
crawling back to me all hot and bothered
and I accept you for what
what is it because she's so pure and
virginial that you you can't you can't
mess with her because you're saving her
for marriage and I'm just the one that
you with or is it because she's not
falling for your charms is that it
great
I'm sorry I am
I I didn't mean to speak out a term
I didn't mean to be cruel I just um
I was really hoping that we
could talk
meaning you know I love you
I've loved you since the first time I
saw you
and I I didn't mean any of it
I just I I treasure every moment that we
have together and I
I just thought
bye
let me cut
yeah
that's a ton of dialogue girl yeah
that's all right nobody knows about you
and me we couldn't tell yeah nobody
knows nobody knows here's the thing to
remember once you're in motion you don't
stop
only the director says cut
or the DP they're the only people that
say cut actors don't cut a scene you
know
even William H Macy doing his eighth or
ninth season of Reckless
you know in the middle of a very
dramatic scene he went up on his lines
and he stopped he kept his attention and
focus on his partner because we know the
key to this whole thing is if you're
doing it correctly total concentration
of attention away from yourself is a
creative source of acting he stopped
kept his concentration said line please
and they gave him the line he backed up
two lines and picked it up and they
keep going
keep going the script coordinator will
make a note the director will make a
note they'll do a pickup shot don't you
worry that's not your you don't worry
about that that's not your job
does their job
don't try to take church I'll have to be
mad
you know you do your job
okay so nobody knows if you drop a line
trust me I know
you know maybe your partner knows
sometimes
but not always
you get more comfortable yeah I know it
you're yeah
okay are we ready
everybody simmered ready in the booth
[Music]
at least those
on the ammo
we are rolling
sound is speeding we have a mark
whenever you're ready
you're not leaving I have to go
so you come here unannounced you drink
all my wine you me you leave me
high and dry and then you're just out of
here you go to the bathroom for about
half an hour and then you come out you
change in the dark expect me not to say
anything not even to notice it's pretty
obvious you go in your dinner
party right now okay don't be mad I told
you about the dinner party last week I
reminded you about the dinner party
today when I arrived a couple hours ago
you did not care you were very welcoming
yeah but now I do care okay because it's
your last night in LA and I expect that
we be together especially after we spent
several hours together in bed
I mean normally you give me supper and
and we cuddle in bed for a while okay I
mean
like I am
Shane
I'm sorry I am
I I didn't want your last moments here
to be the whole
I just I I love you
I'm sorry I didn't mean to make it I'm
not mad okay
and there's nothing to be sorry for
so stop trying to make yourself feel
guilty okay it doesn't matter Michelle
it doesn't matter
you know I think it does matter
especially after this evening I think
it's pretty clear that the reason why
you don't want to be with me is because
there's somebody else
okay
and that proves what person you're
using me that you've been using
me this whole time I'm not using you
you're not using me and using me just
like Dan Hardy I think he's a
because he's invited me to the
dinner party okay well he's not holding
it Allison Ridley is and she doesn't
know you she doesn't know about a
relationship because we both decided to
keep everything everything separate Our
lives our friends we didn't become that
perfect twosome
our relationship has never had any
strings because of you if I recall
correctly
and besides you never liked my friends
until today so
because it changed my mind
it's very nice
it's your last night here I
can I just come with you to the dinner
party please no you can't you know you
know that not the slit of an hour it's a
seated dinner party
so stop trying to make me feel guilty
all of you guys make me want to vomit
yeah the parties you know
when they're all villains
you and your your precious little Elite
Circle
never involving anyone else but
yourselves you're just a bunch of Rich
knobs that's what you are all the money
so hateful of everybody else but your
own selves yeah I think you're
incestuous
just hanging out at your Beverly Hills
mansions in your country clubs never
allowing any Outsiders it's sick it's
disgusting yeah I have to go it's late
okay I'm
I'm sorry this ended on a bad note but
there's nothing left to be said
and I I really wish we could have been
friends but friends
friends
get out of here
leave
go with your girlfriend I know
she's at that dinner party go with her
was she some debutante from some country
club some rich little family is that why
you don't want to bring her around
there's one thing I don't get why night
after night I'm the one you come
crawling back to
is it because she's too precious to be
deflowered
she's a virgin
I don't want to ruin her before marriage
is it because you just bumped your
game
it doesn't fall for your charm and your
fancy clothes maybe she's more Rich than
she there
I'm sorry
that was um
it's kind of cruel
I am
I love you
I really want to spend your last night
together
if you want me
I didn't mean to be cruel you know I
just the first time I saw you I
knew that you were the one for me
cut
give that girl a present
yeah good good good good good good work
yeah you know I bipolar
bipolar plus uh okay Rochelle and Mr
Abner
we have speed we have Mark
action
um the doctor said we could stay here in
the chapel and talk
okay
sure
what are we gonna do
I don't know
it's not fair
none of it
that poor little thing
you know it has a heart
is beating
right
how can that be
how could it have such a tiny healthy
heart
but everything else be so
maybe it's not for us to understand uh
we understand well enough
it is what it is
it's got multiple birth defects that's
what the doctor said please don't call
her it
she has a name
Melanie
she's a human being
she's alive
she belongs to you and to me that's not
true
she does belong to me nor do you either
she is no part of us
what do you think those doctors can do
with surgery
make her a whole person from a sort of
parts
you're mistaken anything that they can't
do a damn thing
the doctor said a decision must be made
now
oh God Is Right
you're the one who believes in all that
crap
so tell me
what does your God tell you to do now
a key part alive
and to take care of her forever it's
been seven days today
I'm saying it's appropriate to me that
on the seventh day
your God rested so
today is resting where
going fishing out to lunch be back in an
hour
you get the bastard back here because I
want to talk to him now
don't
don't talk like that
is this in God's fault whose fault is it
it's not for us to understand whose
fault is it my yours it isn't anybody's
fault I don't accept that
please
you know maybe maybe we shouldn't have
used birth control pill maybe you
shouldn't have experimented drugs back
in your college days
what you heard me
are you blaming me
are you saying that this is my fault
you did drugs too back then maybe it's
your fault I need to know why I'm baby
was born like this
it's God's will
we must accept that
she's a special baby they're a special
schools oh no no no no
mistake
no you know what honest to Christ they
gave us the wrong one
deal with this
serious
I cannot handle this for the rest of my
life
you know what
I refuse to be responsible for saying
nobody can make me
but Melanie is our responsibility
she's all we have
and we're going to tell the doctor to do
the operation
to do everything in his power to give
her the best possible chance in this
world serious what chance does it have
just what it
no no no
we are not going to we have to no we
don't have to and we won't it's not fair
to
her
she didn't ask to be born
we wanted her
and we're going to tell the doctor to do
everything that he can
I love her and I don't care what you say
she has just as much a right to live as
you do
and we're going to tell him to do what
he can
no we won't
because if I have to
I'll stop a living myself
and damn you
no you won't
God God will give us the strength no
shut up shut up
I've heard all I want to hear about your
absentee God it does not exist
stop it
please
please please please please let us help
her
all right wait all right it'll it'll be
all right okay I promise you
it'll be all right okay just we we will
all right we will talk to the doctor
again okay
let's please
please don't Don't Cry Anymore
and cut
s
nice work okay that was really good uh
yeah
yeah you have a slow roll Slow Burn okay
you know but that's okay if that's the
way you felt like doing it that's the
way you do it you know
Jack Nicholson says if you get a feeling
go with it you know if it's not right
the dark rules they take do
pretty simple
you know pretty simple everything we're
doing here is simple guys you're just
not easy
you know
this process is simple simple simple
simple lovely work good for both of you
thank you okay
ready to do it again
yeah change it up it's up to you change
it up I don't want to give you a
redirect because there's no reason to if
there was something that wasn't working
I'd tell you but it's working so if it
ain't broke don't fix it
you know let go a little more be a
little Freer with her
you know I feel you holding back a
little bit
don't hold back
all right
you're rolling
sound is speeding
we have a mark
whenever you're ready
the doctor said we could stay in the
chapel and talk
what are we gonna do
I don't know
it's not fair is it
a poor little thing
it has a heart
it's beating I mean how can that be
how can it have such a tiny healthy
heart
and everything else be so
maybe it's not for us to understand we
understand it well enough
it is what it is
it's got multiple birth defects
that's what the doctor said
please don't call her it
she has a name
Melanie
she's a human being she's alive
and she belongs to you and me
that's not true
she doesn't belong to me
or do you either
part of us
what do you think those doctors can do
with surgery make her a whole person
from assorted parts
you're mistaken if you think that they
can't do a damn thing
well they said a decision must be made
now
oh God oh God Is Right you believe in
all that crap
what does your God tell you to do now
to keep her alive
and to take care of her
it's been seven days today
seems appropriate to me that on the
seven day your God rested
so today is resting resting where
going fishing out to lunch back an hour
is that what he's doing well you get the
bastard back here right now because I
want to talk to him right now
don't
don't talk like that this is not God's
fault whose fault is it
maybe we don't understand no no whose
fault is it tell me mine yours what this
isn't anybody's fault I do not accept
that
please
all right maybe maybe we we shouldn't
have used birth control pills no maybe
you shouldn't have done all the
experimentation with drugs during your
college days
what you heard me
are you blaming me
are you saying that this is my fault
you took drugs too back then maybe it's
your fault no I need to know right now
why our baby is born like this it's
God's will
so what's going to tell me now we will
grow up and we'll take you to some kind
of well those special schools or
something like that now no no I don't
want to hear it
is all a mistake it's just a big mistake
honestly Christ you know they just gave
us the wrong one that's what it is
I can't deal with this
I'm serious
I can't handle this for the rest of my
life
you know what
I refuse to be responsible for this
nobody can make me
but we are responsible for Melanie
we are all she has
and we're going to tell the doctor to do
the operation
we're going to tell him to do everything
in his power to give her the best
possible chance chance for what what
chance does it have no no no no
we're not going to we have to no we
don't have to and we're not going to
it's not fair to it
she didn't ask to be born
we wanted her
I love her
and I don't care what you say she has as
much a right to live as you do
so we're going to tell him to do
whatever he can no we won't
if I have to
I will stop reliving myself damn you
no you won't
do that
God will give us the strength no no no
I've heard all I want to hear about your
absentee God
exist stop it
God is that special little baby
God Is You and me and our little girl
please
just let them help her
they'll be all right all right I promise
you I promise
it'll be all right we'll we'll go ahead
and we'll talk to the doctors now okay
please
anymore okay we'll be all right
all right we'll talk to dogs again okay
good good good stay up there Ty you're
gonna do it again got another one in you
so yeah yeah good good light nice
Michelle good for you
Genie's doing it again because she had
it scheduled to do last week and her
partner uh was called out of town so
we're gonna throw her to the wolves
are you comfortable
are we simmered where's simmered okay
we're rolling
we have a mark
action
three said we could um use the Chapel to
talk for a while okay
sure
oh my God what are we gonna do I don't
know
it's it's not fair none of it
well maybe did that poet poor little
things you know you know it has a heart
and it's beating
how can that be
how can it have a tiny healthy heart and
everything else be so just
I don't think that's for us to
understand so we understand it well
enough
it is what it is it's got multiple birth
defects that's what the doctor said
can you please not color in it
her name is Melanie
she's a human she's her baby and she
belongs to you and me no that's not true
she doesn't belong to me
well I'm only you either she's no part
of us
because what do you think those doctors
can do with surgery make her a whole
person not a sort of part like a
Frankenstein or something you're
mistaken if you think that I can do a
damn thing
yeah well the doctor says we have to
make a decision by tonight so
I'm waiting for you to hear some of your
all your pontificating blabbing about
God because you don't want to believe in
that what does your God till you do now
he tells me to keep her alive and care
for her forever you know it's been seven
days
if I remember correctly seems
appropriate to me then on the seventh
day your God rested so today's resting
where where going fishing out to lunch
backing out no you get the medicine back
here and tell them I want to hear you
right now stop talking like that
don't talk about God like that whose
fault is it
we don't know why these things happen
whose fault is it mine yours it's not
anybody's fault I don't accept that
please just
please
yeah you know maybe maybe we shouldn't
have experiment with birth control pills
you know what and maybe you shouldn't
have experimented with drugs back in
your college day you heard me well
you're saying it's my fault because I
took drugs
you took drugs two babies your
fault I need to know why our baby was
born like this
because it's God's will
and she's a special baby and and we're
gonna take her to special no no no no
shut up shut up shut up no it's a
mistake
honestly Christ they just gave us the
wrong one that that that that's it it
just gave us the wrong one
I can't deal with this
look at me
I'm serious
I cannot handle this for the rest of my
life
you know what you know what I refuse to
be responsible for it nobody can make me
you know what
we're gonna go to those doctors
we're gonna tell them do the surgery
and we're gonna tell them to give her
the best chance
what chance do you think it has chance
for what no no no we
are not going to we have to no we don't
have to
and we weren't going to it's not fair
her
you know she didn't ask to be born
no seriously we wanted her
I love her
and I am going to those doctors whether
or not you want to because she has a
right to live just as much as you do no
we won't and if I have to I will stop
her living myself
damn you
that's not in you
we are going to do this
and God is going to help us there no no
I have heard all I'm gonna hear about
your absentee God
it doesn't exist
see God is in this little girl
God is in you and God is in me
and we're gonna trust him
please
it'll be all right okay I promise you
I promise
it'll be all right okay but we'll talk
we'll talk to the doctors again okay
please
don't don't cry anymore okay
it'll be okay
very cut
oh okay okay good okay yeah okay that's
it for taping guys let's uh cold read
okay simmer Please
Mr Keating asks for simmer they were
done by the late 90s
all right whenever you're ready
how the have you been great
why is there no furniture here Tim is
moving thanks for returning my phone
calls you dick sorry I've only been back
for like four days been I don't know I
but I've been looking for you well here
I am what can I do for you dude what
have you got what did you take up there
well in hard course in a writing course
in this music course music course
did you write any music yeah a little
hey I got some lyrics
write some music we'll make millions
millions of what
are you going back are you going to stay
and play in LA where
Jesus to school you jerk I don't know I
suppose so you suppose so yeah
cute scarf real cute guess Blair still
likes you I guess you guess you guess
it's good how about a gram here you go
dude keep your money Christmas present
okay
thanks a lot rip
I think you should go back don't
off don't be a bum like you like me dude
I don't know if I want to what do you
mean you don't know if you don't if you
want to I don't know things are
different here listen you've got a long
vacation don't you a month right yeah
four weeks
a month right
think about it I'll do that
okay good short and sweet but you know
if you do you do a piece simmer please
guys you do a piece like this on a on a
hit TV show you do a short scene like
that remember no small rolls just small
actors
you can't have stinking thinking you
know
do the gig
do a great job do your best commit the
rest forget about it okay yeah you know
yeah good it's there's a lot in this
piece
so don't ever look at a two and a half
or three page piece and don't think oh I
mean I have never thought that I know
it's a it's a reminder for everybody you
know it's just a reminder for everybody
okay uh Blake you want her to work next
Blake and Kenny
I don't give you line readings and I
don't tell you what to expect that's
your job
do you bring your soul to the character
that's why they hired you
they hired you because when you audition
you gave them something that they were
looking for
you know don't go there to please them
or anything go there Pacino says act
it's your chance to act
go there and kick ass
you know don't give them what you think
they want you know why they don't know
what they want
you know if I was up for a role in a
feature film that shot in the midwest a
couple years ago
and and I'm white white-haired white
bearded and six three and they went with
a five foot two Chinese guy obviously
they didn't know what they were looking
for
and I know my audition was very good
because the director told me it was very
good
so they don't know they don't always
know
so you can't take anything personally
it's totally subjective
you know if you're a blonde and a
beautiful woman and you go to an
audition and the directors
ex-wife is blonde and beautiful and he
hates her guts you're not going to get
the role is that fair no is life no
okay
there you go I learned something new
today I learned that in 1905 a hundred
thousand dollars
was a hundred thousand dollars but today
it's the equivalent of three million
so when the Rockefellers and the
Kennedys and all those people were doing
illegal to make all their Millions
it was because
that's how much that money was worth
then stop and think about it
and a loaf of bread was a nickel
or cheaper
are we ready
in the booth we are totally ready okay
cool listos
[Music]
thank you Kenny
grades came today Todd
yeah I know
1B
4 C's One D
one day
got a d for Christ's sakes Todd your
mother's not showing it but she's really
upset I
got you've never got a report like this
a d
in beginning algebra what what is this I
don't know Dad
all right your mother and I think you
spend too much time with Mr Denker we
think you should cut down the time you
spend on the weekends what no Dad please
don't that I
I'm so loud me I'll do better really
that algebra just threw me to start with
I just messed up it won't happen again
no you're spending way too much time
with him Mr stormman the algebra teacher
is really hard lots of kids give these
three or four
I won't go on Wednesdays anymore and
they'll study extra hard
I really like the old guy that much
he's really neat and tells great stories
plus he needs companionship
I'm just thinking of your future
you know junior high is not too soon to
start thinking about it but for now
try it your way thanks Steph and I
promise I'll work extra hard
and cut okay a lot in the piece how
old so it's important that you finish
okay it must be my son you only did you
know when you said me you get an
operating on me and and that very end
your last line you give me an up where
you don't no upbrings never do an upward
guys remember go through your script
take out that punctuation writers write
the way writers write they don't write
the way people speak
so it's your job to look at the copy at
the words
and extrapolate the meaning
you know exclamation point most Bad
actors think that means you have to yell
or exaggerate don't do that
well you know a question mark do I say
David how are you today no I say how are
you today it's a question
if it's written as a question and you
make it a statement is going to sound
like a question
leave it alone just leave it alone
take out the periods we don't talk
period that that that period that that
that period we don't do that geez my
whole life is one long run on sentence
you know that's the way we talk
so just be careful only twice though and
that's the first time tonight so good
for you all right keep working on it
kiddo you've got it wolf connection nice
your good dad
let's see uh Jill and Felix
you do
[Music]
you do Joel you have a scene okay
it's ours babe
I'm putting in a teardrop window
what do you mean
if it's worse
traded her in
don't worry I got this below sale
price Super Deal
you know about it three days ago but
there was some paperwork
surprise
you bought this thing without even
telling me they install these windows
for you at the dealership but it's like
a rip-off you know I'm saving about a
hundred and a half
you like it I mean come on do you like
it you and I are going on our belated
cross-country honeymoon trip first week
of August
I I just can't pick up and go on a
three-week vacation I only get one week
vacation no it's all taken care of I I
called what's his face you know your
boss right and he finally agreed to give
you a week with pay plus two weeks off
without pay
you planned a vacation without even
asking well you know I'm putting in the
shag carpet down on the floor you know
Boomers got a Remnant left from their
place all the Comforts of home huh like
come on what's not to like about it well
come on say something
uh uh
um I thought you were going to write
poems all summer you
said that's what you needed to do
travel will feed my writing you know
Feed the Beast I figured you can take
the wheel when I drive and I just
I thought you'd be excited about it
I don't know I think it was easy putting
all this together
but a lot of that money was my
grandmother she gave it to us
oh okay I get it I get it yeah all right
yeah hands off of the wedding stash
because she's my grandmother not yours
never realized you're such a
materialist before Little Miss equity
that's not the point how about this man
whatever whatever the her name is
doesn't doesn't she get her usual vote
in this too
look I wanted to surprise you with this
honeymoon we never got to have not that
our marriage needs a jump start or
anything not that we have any room for
any wedded bliss
and that's it
you got it that's it
[Laughter]
Andrea and Kai
and yes Kai
yes Kai I know you're not a grandfather
but
Lou Gossett Jr started playing
grandfathers when he was 30. so I
figured if Lou gossip could do it you
could do it
they aged him
yeah because because he was capable of
doing it in a very similar please and a
very good friend of mine who just got an
Oscar for writing uh couple years ago
Kevin Wilmot who's a fabulous actor he
in one of his early films that he wrote
and shot in Kansas City he played 39th
Street it was a history of 39th Street
which was where all the black bars were
in Lawrence Kansas uh
during World War II
he played a grandfather in that and he
was at that time probably only 35-38
so yeah I mean that's why we're actors
isn't it
you know
I don't want a real job
hi Grandpa
what's going on I have something to tell
you
what's wrong
see I'll tell you something okay what is
it
back 20 years before your grandma died
we decided to put some money back for
you kids so you have down payment for
your home
it's in 30 month CDs
last three times it matured
I wanted to give it to you kids but
your mother won't let me
promise me
something that should happen to me
you'll get it
I'm surprised mom even let you good
morning CDs for us to begin with
and how they should find out
I have to Lisa got remarried I had to
change with a new married name
came in the mail with a name on and care
of me
I can't walk to the mailbox anymore so
your mother found out when she picked up
over there
I bet I went over like a little
she wasn't very happy
she said you kids didn't need it she
said the boys are both as an alcohol
drugs and women
Lisa's husband was in a would end up
with all hers and
you and Debbie just didn't need it all
Grandpa what in the world happened to
your arm
that is where your mom hit me
oh my God was that last Sunday a little
Skippy birthday party
okay I call over just after she had done
it and she had the nerve to tell me
about it
if I had been there I don't know what I
would have done
there is no excuse for a 55 year old
woman to hit an 85 year old period no
excuse at all and I told her so
what did she say
she reminded me the time I broke my
mother's finger
time she went around telling everyone
should have done it
yeah that's the time
she was coming at me and you know how
she throws these hands up to grab you
well I threw up mine to blockers and our
fingers interlaced
I guess being scared to death gave me a
strength and I didn't know I had
and I just snapped her finger
Grandpa baby and I discussed have
discussed that and we think we should
have Mom come here no
cost any trouble your long bills at the
grocery store for me and picks up my
mail every day I don't want to stir up
anything
I've already forgiven her but
I'll never forget what she did as long
as I live okay grandpa but if it happens
again you won't have any choice we will
have her committed she bit us she bit us
kids every day of Our Lives
and she's not starting on you
She's Dangerous Grandpa
I don't think you should know how
dangerous
okay there's a lot in this piece so when
you memorize it yeah
you can do it you can do it man you you
can do it I know you can do it two
things lead balloon lead yeah lead
balloon and then when you when Jill send
you the material that you did tonight in
your earlier piece that you did with Mr
uh bedroom uh look at the the in take
one look at where you talk about
wallowing it dig it and look at the
difference in your transition the second
take on those same lines because
it's really interesting I want you to
see the difference in the take one and
take two just in that sequence okay yeah
you'll see and tell me what you see okay
good uh let's see uh Rochelle and Mr CMS
uh
whenever you're ready
what the hell is going on John
Janice you're trembling I
I knew that funeral last week must have
been unbearable for you
and Sarah let me write you a
prescription for a sedative it'll help
you calm down I don't want a sedative I
want some answers
you and Jack have been best friends
since College you and I both know Jack
was as healthy as a horse he had never
been sick a day in his life there was
never any history of heart problems in
Jack's family
and yet you expect me to believe that he
actually died from a heart attack Janice
you've read the autopsy report the U.S
attorney general conducted a formal
investigation
it's over Janice I'm sorry
don't you find it odd that Jenny will
fly out to conduct a personal
investigation
especially for some small small town
Memphis lawyer
Jack was no small town lawyer he was a
partner in one of the largest firms in
Memphis how much did Jack tell you about
why he was about what he was working on
well he told me that he had an upcoming
trip to to blightsville and he said that
he wanted to conduct his own
investigation I mean Christ why why
couldn't that husband of yours be
satisfied with staying inside the
courtroom why did he always have to be
Dick Tracy too
John
Jack called that money that Monday from
Blytheville
he found what he was looking for
he told me that he didn't think he would
make it out alive
he was right
John I'm afraid
I'm afraid for my life and for Sarahs
you know it's a matter of National
Security and you know that such
Preposterous conclusions not be released
to the press such conclusions you know
could harm the president's image as well
as ruin your career to save you from any
further embarrassment and whatever you
know I'm relieving you of your duties
those were her exact words I mean it
didn't make sense at the time but oh boy
now it does
what did Jack die from
what is anthrax Anthrax is a steroid
used on cattle now ranchers use it to
produce meteor livestock you know a
research team at UT Martin found out
that when when it was injected into
smaller animals It produced heart
failures
you know because it's a steroid the uh
the heart attack occurs naturally unless
you're specifically looking for traces
of the steroid no doctors would ever
know that it wasn't a heart attack
how did you know to look for the drug
John
well
I put together the research team at UT
Martin
bad dude
okay you're right
Adam and Mr Keating
my associate tells me you alluded to me
as a first class jerk
I didn't want you I didn't want to use
stronger language in front of them I
never liked
to see a robot blush
what exactly do you want they also told
me you referred to me as a Becky
not a term of endearment prefer not to
be called a Becky oh yeah
thank you
fine
why am I here that's precisely what I'm
most anxious to learn
what does bring you to London
personal business
you may recall that I didn't care for
you when you were a California police
officer and come poking around in London
some years ago
yeah
I find it I find
I care for you even less right now
right now that you're nothing more than
a private investigator
I dislike you about the same as I did
back seven years ago
no more no less
the Sun and soldier case is one I don't
want anyone interfering with
well now
you don't have any jurisdiction in
France don't try playing schoolboy games
you're much too far along and you're
super young pardon to bring it off
cardigan there's been a new Killing yeah
right here in England I assumed you
already knew that
isn't that why you came over to England
in such a rush
no it isn't
who's the victim
Senator Ainsworth
he was murdered outside the apartment of
his current mistress
his Sky car pilot was only shot with a
stun gun
Ainsworth of course was killed by having
his body quartered
do all the details match the other
killings the description of the killers
match
this method was the same
what something's bothering you
I know you've been hired to look into
the murder of Joseph but
Joseph
are there really any indications that he
wasn't a victim of the unknown social
Soldier
some yeah
I know he left last night contained A
variation
which was
in addition to his usual message
he added a PostScript
instead of one word
true
which could mean that this was a true
Unknown Soldier kill and not an
imitation
you're thoroughly convinced there are
two separate killers
there seems to be
there's the Unknown Soldier and there's
the Kathy cop copycat who did it in
Bouchon
look
you give me your word you're not here to
interview with this investigation
until you told me
I didn't even know there had been a new
Killing where are you staying
the Crystal Palace Hotel
you may consider our interview at an end
okay
so there could be cut
yeah
that's okay
okay so so gentlemen
you can be much more dismissive
and upset that he's in your
territory again right
you have positional Authority
he's there nosing around
so
let him know that okay okay
and you just don't give a
you're following up on a lead you had
and you don't care what he thinks about
you being there Max and Gene
yeah good Max hey guys this is just a
note for everybody uh if you're not cold
reading aloud 30 minutes every day I can
tell
I don't care if I'm ever in front of a
camera again
although I did enjoy doing the film I
did two years ago
but
I still code read aloud 30 minutes every
day I have every day since 1970.
I do it because I won't ask you to do
something I'm not willing to do
but I can only suggest that you do it I
can't force you to do it
but I do know after 70 plus years of
being a working actor not just someone
walking around with a script under my
arm saying I'm a bartender but I want to
be an actor a working actor I know how
important these skills are
because you've heard me say this before
and Jeannie wrote it in her her new
writings that she wrote your craft will
support you when your knees won't
and it's important that you understand
that
this is a business guys like any other
business
if you don't stay on top of your stuff
somebody else would come by and Gobble
you up there's always a faster gun in
the West
okay
remember that
skinny do
why are we making small talk gem when
you're troubled
I know something's wrong
can you just please tell me what it is
darling
I want to know what's bothering you
I suppose there's no putting it off
I had a bit of a set too with Winston
today again
is that all
I mean you've had clashes with him
before and they always blow over so this
will just I've resigned you've resigned
as managing editor of the company that
is effective immediately
why
and why didn't you mention it to me and
tell me what was on your mind I mean I
simply don't understand
I didn't think I was going to resign
until I did
Jim this is perfectly ridiculous just
because you had a little row with
Winston doesn't mean you have to do
something as drastic as this as dramatic
I mean after all Grandy has the final
word you know that
she appointed you and and she'll
reinstate you at once and and she'll put
Winston straight deal with him
look I'll
I'll speak with her tomorrow ring her
first thing in the morning and it'll
just all be
I'm afraid you're misunderstanding me
Winston didn't force me to resign or
anything like that
if that's what you're thinking I did so
of my own accord I wanted to and rather
badly although I must admit an ultra
thinness I didn't realize this until the
opportunity presented itself
so I certainly don't want to be
reinstated but why not For Heaven's Sake
because I don't like the job
never have when Winston came to me to me
this morning I
asked if I would if I wished to continue
as managing director and as he was
speaking I knew really knew Paula that I
didn't
I've never been particularly good at
administrative work or interested in it
and I told Winston so and he said he
sends he sends this for some time
he pointed out that perhaps it would be
better if I stuck to journalism
I ran papers for the for the company
I thoroughly agree with him so I stepped
down
that's all there is to it actually
all there is to it
that I'm hearing you say these things
you're acting as though it doesn't
matter as if this wasn't serious when
it's terribly serious
and you're being so Cavalier so
dismissive I am absolutely staggered
don't get so head up frankly I'm felt
relief
relief should be the last thing on your
mind
I mean what about Duty what about
responsibility
you know Granny showed a great deal of
faith in you put her trust in you when
when when she appointed you to manager
director last year
and I think that you've let her down
rather badly I'm sorry you feel that way
because I must disagree with
I haven't like Randy down
I'm still going to be managing editor in
charge of two of the most important
newspaper in the Consolidated group
I'll be doing
best being a newspaper man and I had a
damn good one at that
who's gonna run the company now that
you've stepped down
instant
very well
he doesn't want that job
neither do I
hope this sudden and rather
extraordinary decision of yours doesn't
mean that Grandy will have to cancel her
trip with blocking
she really needs this holiday
what did she say I mean I presume that
you've already told her naturally I've
told her
Winston I walked over to the store at
lunch time for a meeting with her
your grandmother accepted my rest my
resignation
Winston's agreed to take the job and he
didn't seem very perturbed about the
idea either Grandy isn't going to cancel
her holiday rest assured of that come on
relax
you're the one who's more upset than
anyone
Randy and Winston respect my decision
they didn't quibble
in fact there was very little discussion
it was rather cut and dried actually
I think you've simply misunderstood
their reactions now you're being
ridiculous Paula I I know them both very
well and I can assure you that
everything is all right
for your sake it is
good it's a wonderful piece grow not row
row is a British term for argument
around so if you want to change it to
argument
oh do I say that yeah
you said bro
somewhere in their page two I middle of
page two I think but it's not like I
know all the material I just know all
the materials
but it's somewhere in the middle of page
two okay guys uh look
um
some really good work tonight you know
you know you should feel all all of you
should feel really good about uh
everything that was done look it it's
just consistency
you've got to keep doing it oh I don't
have the money I can't do that I can't
but you can go to Starbucks every day
and spend eight bucks on a cup of coffee
you know I'm not telling you how to
spend your money
I'm just telling you not you especially
Moneybags uh I I
I do a giveaway I know but no giveaways
when we have guests because the owner
guest might have won maybe we should
have done a giveaway no I'm just saying
you know that it's it's doing it and
doing it and doing it you're getting it
plateaus that's why I ask everybody that
starts there to buy the book Mastery by
George Leonard and read it if you've
been here longer than a week and you
haven't purchased that it's free online
get it online for free read the damn
book it's only 124 Pages it only costs
14.95 I think if you want to buy it but
it's free
you know and if you don't have money
there's a library nearby that you know
check it out at the library oh I didn't
have a library card get one they're free
you know it's like gel says about cold
reading all the time don't spend 800 on
a cold reading class I have two separate
sheets of paper and five minutes of my
time I will gladly give you 15 minutes
20 minutes 30 minutes and teach out a
cold read for free
but cold readers are skill that you have
to develop
working on your craft daily is something
you have to develop I say it all the
time and then I'll say good night
dancers dance and stretch every day
whether they're working or not
singers vocalize and sing every day
musicians play their instrument every
day
whether they're working or not and
actors sit on their ass and wait for the
phone to ring and if you're one of those
actors when the phone rings guess what
you are not ready
so I want you to be ready I want you to
be prepared the Chinese symbols
for
opportunity and preparation when put
together our success
now that's a that's a diagrammatic
language that's over 6 000 years old
they knew something
because it's still true
if you're not prepared when the
opportunity arises you don't get the
brass ring
you keep missing it
there it is there it is there's a great
Tchaikovsky quote
um Tchaikovsky you know wrote 1812
Overture Romeo and Juliet
Nutcracker Swan Lake Sleeping Beauty
ballet just a couple things yeah
um so he's qualified
he said inspiration is a guest that does
not willingly visit the lazy
on that note everybody
have a great night be safe stay healthy
be well and thank you both David and
Karen so much for being here tonight I
hope you got something worthwhile I
don't know thank you already